Wow 12 series 10 episodes 9 stories
let's rank it
[Applause]
all right folks it is that time series
12 ended and I need to rank these now
even though there were 10 episodes I am
in fact going to be ranking them as 9
stories now I could I suppose rank it as
8 I have decided to break up ascension
of the Cybermen and the timeless
children but I am doing spy fall as one
story so let us move on forward from
here starting at the bottom to the
absolute shock of nobody orphan 55 oh
boy
this thing was just badly executed on
pretty much every level and like let's
be really clear about this the fact that
it has an environmental message is not
the reason that it's bad the fact that
that message is delivered incredibly
clunky the fact that we have monsters
that only look good in the dark suddenly
being shown in broad daylight the fact
that it has awful clunky gear grinding
transitions from act 2 act as we go from
the resort out into the tank and then
we're trying to run then we're running
through corridors the transitions
between all those are awful the
supporting character performances a lot
of them are not good they're painful
penny ya know this and then to capital
off with practically a direct turn to
camera you should take better care the
environment viewer it's not there's
something especially infuriating when
when something is a message episode
that's a message I agree with and I
still am rolling my eyes going you gotta
be freaking kidding me
hey moving up one spot to number eight
and before I get to this let me just say
that orphan 55 there's actually a big
gap quality-wise between that one and
the next one so even though this next
one is my second to bottom you know
second worse technically like
there's a big drop-off here so number
eight is practice so I practice is also
an environmental message episode but it
is handled much better than orphan 55is
although at the end of the day it's
ultimately still just kind of middling I
like some of the elements of some of the
supporting cast but there is other
members of the guest cast that are just
fodder and their deaths get next no
acknowledgement which is weird and I
didn't care for that the I found the
apraxia is virus in the way that works
to actually be really creepy kind of
just really hit my buttons as far as
that borderline body horror like see
like climb up the face ah so like that
was really well done but it just it felt
just a little bit undercooked it felt
like you needed another pass to tighten
things up a little bit and really get
the pieces connecting yeah it really
started to come into her own as a
character in this one though I got to
give it that number 7 nikola tesla's
night of terror i know some people
really liked this one and i liked it
fine it just for me it's it's just good
it's not great it's just good as far as
Doctor encounters famous historical
figure goes it's one of the better ones
I do think I think Nikola Tesla as a
character lends himself a little bit
better to these sorts of things than
some of the some of the other celebrity
historical figures that have been used
over the years just because of the
nature of the guy and his own inherent
curiosity him so him slotting into a
Doctor Who story is actually really
natural it would spark his natural
curiosity and then you know with him and
Edison and having the this race of
scavengers sort of mirror that
relationship between Tesla and Edison it
it was competently put together it just
didn't really light my fire and so
number 6 the timeless children now given
how angry I got during my rant for that
episode I
some people are probably surprised that
it's this high but here's the thing to
remember and I said this in my review at
the time everything that isn't the
reveal above the twist of the timeless
child is really well done I feel I think
the Masters great I think they found
good stuffer - for the Companions to do
and to keep them busy I thought they had
the supporting cast had good solid
interactions the master is great and
even the reveal itself the way it's done
isn't awful it's not great the doctor is
very much sort of in a separate story
bubble from everything else going on but
it really only is the thing that was
revealed that I really really really
don't like I can't really knock the
delivery I can't really knock the
messenger like the episode is not a bad
episode it's actually quite good in a
lot of ways but the message of what we
learned about the doctor I do have
enough issues with that I'm not going
higher than 6 but it's what kept it out
of the bottom of the barrel rankings
first areas that one detail makes me
it's actually a minority element of the
episode which is its own sort of weird
thing but there you go
so moving our way up brings us to number
five spy fall lumping together parts one
and two obviously the highlight of this
is the reveal of the new master I love
the reveal moment was really well done I
loved the return of the tissue
compressor
I liked the DA I like the sari the
master sort of bumping into the doctor
again at several points over history I'd
I saw I liked how that worked
I thought the aliens and the sort of way
that they worked was unnerving and
unsettling and like a little off-putting
I'm like that's weird I kind of dig it
there are a few things holding it back
though I feel like the human villain the
degree to which he goes especially at
the end and what he does to his mother
I'm like why what is what is go
with that so like there's some elements
that don't quite pull together but on
the other hand it's got the doctor in a
tux and I did that number for ascension
of the Cybermen this was a very good
build-up to the finale episode I mean a
big part of this is I think Schad is
really good villain I thought it was a
really neat concept for the Cybermen
overall and I thought the execution of
that concept was really really good and
a really neat I dug the hell out of him
so sort of watching him just come
through and just completely up and the
situation that that's going on and and
the doctor watching me and you're
getting the sense from basically
everybody like yeah that's a Cyberman
but something's off and something's
weird and we don't know if we can figure
out I deal with this but we're gonna try
it had a great sense of tension and it
and it felt dangerous the Cybermen have
not felt this dangerous in a long time
because like even world enough in time
which I love a Cyberman didn't feel
dangerous they felt creepy they felt
unsettling which was incredibly
effective for that episode but they
didn't feel dangerous they feel like a
threat in this one and I have got to
give serious props for that
so moving our way up to number three the
hunting of Villa dia daddy see I can say
it I still probably said it wrong
whatever this one has a really nice vibe
I love the haunted house vibe on this I
really dig the heck out of it and it's
very well executed
I love the illogical architecture you
know they go through a door and come
back into the exact same room they left
love that the the lighting the mood the
introduction of the lone Cybermen and
just how unsettling he is and how he
fits into that the performances from the
supporting cast also very good
the the valet he was terrific I do have
my issues I brought them up in the
episode the the casualness with which
the servants are dispatched and
especially given how well developed they
were and also there's some grand icing
of the writer that really rubbed me the
wrong way but the mood and the feel and
the tone of this thing I just dig the
heck out of it and I forgot to mention
this in my review proper I like that
it's applied that Graham just flat-out
saw ghosts I like that it bothers some
people I love that because there should
be some stuff in the universe that the
doctor can't explain is why we should
never get a definitive answer as to
whether or not the thing on the
impossible plan the same put in the
Satan pit was or wasn't the devil some
things even the doctors shouldn't have
the answers to and the possibility that
Graham actually just saw ghosts yeah I
dig it two more to go what are they well
you know what they are you've been
counting down I'm sure but here we go
number two fugitive of the Judoon
I really got swept up in this one it's
easy to do what starts out as like a oh
the Judoon they're hunting somebody oh
it's this guy and he's sending this
person away like oh well they're really
after something else
oh okay so what else is going on wait
what the escalation like and especially
just putting in the title but you do
because the jun have never been you know
parts of massive series and borne
stories if they did they had minor parts
you think if it's gonna be focused on
the Judoon you're gonna you're thinking
in terms of tone of like Smith and Jones
of something lighter like oh well it'll
it'll be a fun time not let's upend
everything by introducing an incarnation
of the doctor we've never freakin seen
before played by Joe Martin excellently
like I don't I want her to come back now
at this point the implication with what
we've learned about the timeless child
is very much implied that she is a pre
hurtle incarnation which I don't love
but I mean at this point we have to
accept that those just exist I I
honest-to-goodness
want them to find a way to have her be
the doctor after Jodie Whittaker like I
want extended time with this doctor she
has such a commanding presence I really
enjoyed her and I want to see more
and I also honestly really liked her
interacting with Whitaker's doctor the
two of them just getting really
irritated with each other I enjoyed the
heck out of that the whole thing just
just has a great rip-roaring it's just
moving and you and it's blowing your
mind at the same time it's telling a
rollicking adventure this was a good
good piece of work but that does mean my
number one probably not most people's
number one and this happened to be last
year because last year my series 11
number one was it takes you away this
year it is can you hear me I can't go
into all the reasons that I love this
over the course of this video I've
obviously got reviews up for all these
episodes so you can check that review
out if you need to but the depth and the
integration of the thematic elements of
depression and anxiety and how they are
embodied by these malicious gods and how
that manifests in the story and how it
centers around yaz and how it centers
around this friend of Ryan's and how all
of this plays out the way that these
things put you know they put two planets
at war with each other
like depression and anxiety will put
parts of your own brain at war with
itself the depth of the theming in this
is so good it is one of those cases
where I love deep theming
but you have to be careful because if
you lean on too much deep theming is not
a substitute for a solid story and I do
feel that this is a solid story and also
this is theming that does truly run deep
it's not just like oh it's about to
present oh that's kind of neat the
instant what I watched it when I had
that thought about halfway through
watching it the first time I had to
watch it again watching this set the
second time with that theme in mind I
realized how much of the episode plays
into that theme it's not just layered on
pretentiously it is carefully woven into
the entire thing I think expertly so I
think it is an incredibly well executed
episode I've heard people make the
argument that should have been a
two-parter I'm not sure it needed to be
I will grant it probably could have used
another 10 15 minutes for the tail end
for the confrontation end of things but
even lacking that I still think this is
a terrific piece of work and for me it
was the best episode of series 12 that
shouldn't be a huge shock I've done two
videos on that episode one here and one
in the breakroom
so that's my ranking what's yours
whatever your thoughts are drop
something on down in the comments let's
talk about it but stuff to do like
subscribe check me out over on patreon
consider supporting me it will be
immensely welcomed and also be a lovely
birthday present for me it is my
birthday this month though if you want
to do something else I've also got an
Amazon wishlist and a p.o box address
down there if you feel like sending me
anything I'll be opening everything on a
live stream on the 24th so that's it for
this one folks so many things that you
can do to help me out and spread the
word but you don't have to end of the
day you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council
it's adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]